what is the meaning of The White Buffalo
who is the monocle what's Harlan like as
an old man here are the small details
you missed in the Umbrella Academy
Season 3.
for those unfamiliar with the Umbrella
Academy Source material the comic book
series by Gerard Way and Gabrielle ba
that began publishing in 2007 the hotel
Oblivion is a direct reference to the My
Chemical Romance front man's third
volume of the family's Story the moment
in this scene that we are referencing
here though is a tip of the cap to the
opening of Orson Welles 1941 classic
Citizen Kane
[Music]
after seeing Reginald's greater plan
unfold in the season 3 finale it's no
surprise he would let out one particular
word in an almost Freudian slip
like the phrase Rosebud and Citizen Kane
the remote dropped an extreme close-up
of Reginald's lips puts tremendous
weight on the word leaving viewers
questioning its meaning comic book fans
however already know the hotel Oblivion
is an impenetrable prison built by the
monocle to hold super villains on top of
that connection the finale also revealed
to the Umbrella Academy that this
Reginald is indeed the green-blooded
cyborg alien known as the monocle
perhaps making fans even more eager for
the next volume of comics as well as
season 4 of the series based on them
eagle-eyed viewers from last season had
been anxiously awaiting the return of
young Harlan in season three after
seeing he retained Victor's immense
Powers fans speculated that this strange
old man with retro headphones a case of
cassette tapes and a suitcase full of
numbered sandwiches was indeed an older
Harlan the season 2 Cliffhanger also
teased Harlan's decimation of Sparrow's
Jamie and Alfonso as seen in season
three's third episode in his hand he's
levitating a bird which could be a
sparrow which foreshadows his explosive
Outburst that fries off the Sparrow's
faces luckily after that event viewers
received a detailed backstory depicting
the trauma Harlan endured which warped
his uncontrollable abilities it was
subsequently explained how Harlan was
able to locate the two superhuman
families his connection to these
super-powered Heroes resonated in his
mind almost like sound waves
the Umbrella Academy Season 3 brought
with it what could potentially be a
Marvel connection at least from the
standpoint of visual effects if you've
never seen the series Legion on the FX
channel it follows an extremely powerful
telepathic mutant the eponymous Legion
who struggles with mental illness as a
result of his mental state it makes it
extremely hard for him to control his
powerful abilities the Umbrella Academy
seems to be evoking the series in both
look and theme Legion shares some of the
same crew members behind the scenes such
as series composer Jeff Russo and
Director of Photography Craig robleski
this likely explains why the explosive
Outburst from Harlan at the beginning of
episode 4 is so similar to David's
kitchen utensil tornado they even look
and sound similar with cool blue tones
and chaotic whirlwinds of dangerous
objects both explosions also come from a
character's deep trauma so even if it
wasn't an intentional callback to that
other trippy superhero Tale the style
and themes definitely carry over thanks
to the talent designing and implementing
the effects
the most familiar face in the sparrow
Academy worked its way up to a brand new
ranking in season three the previous
number six in the family relentlessly
devoted himself to becoming one of the
strongest members of The Sparrows Finn's
horrific Powers allow him to unleash the
Fearsome tentacled Beast Within and it
seems his Fierce dedication has earned
him an upgrade to number two there's
already enough Bad Blood between the
Umbrella Academy and sparrows because of
the first team's arrival in the new
reality however when Ben discovers he
died in their original timeline he's far
less trustworthy of his rambunctious new
siblings after the first episode with
Marcus taken by the cougar Blitz Ben
declares himself the new number one but
in episode 3 his siblings make a passing
remark that tips off the audience that
Ben was the original number one you have
your chance once
didn't turn out too well now did it so
what did he do to get taken down a pack
was this Reginald's Twisted way of
motivating him whatever the reason his
resentment is suddenly far more
understandable
not surprisingly there are more than a
few references to the Umbrella Academy
Source material one being a new look for
fan favorite rumor after Alice and
unsuccessfully tries to rumor herself
into happiness she grabs A Shard of
broken mirror and cuts her hair short
the significance of this transformation
matches her signature style in the
comics any raver Lampman showcases a
deeply moving performance as Alison in
season three gutted to learn her
daughter Claire doesn't exist in this
timeline this sends Alison into a
downward spiral where she even rumors
Luther into wanting to stay with her
because of a desperate desire for any
sense of something familiar she also
argues with Victor about Harlan's faith
and eventually kills the old man for
what he did to The Sparrows this was
Alison's darkest season yet and it
closely resembles her comic book
counterpart
the hotel Oblivion finally makes its
frightening debut through a passageway
behind a wall-mounted Pachinko machine
located in the Buffalo Suite of the
hotel obsidian the hotel is similar to
The Overlook from The Shining albeit
bolstered with interesting additions
like a sushi Carousel murderous Samurai
Guardians and a built-in
universe-changing machine there's also
an abundance of gross cockroaches which
Lila happily squashes another comic book
reference
the biggest note of importance with the
arrival in Oblivion is the reveal of the
ambitious scheme Reginald Cooks up it
adds a necessary layer of Suspicion
which pays off when Allison kills him
the green blood and sparking metallic
skeleton is an extraordinary visual cue
one that reveals to everyone that
Reginald was not who he seemed to be it
also illustrates the Brilliance and
dedication of Reginald who purposefully
built the hotel around a portal he
discovered once the audience discovers
he is the founder of the hotel
everything begins coming together as the
maniacal Genius of the monocle is
revealed at last
potentially the deepest mystery of the
season this Easter egg is quite
intriguing unfortunately even the comics
can't help viewers much here but it does
reveal some information about The
elusive Jennifer in episode 7 after a
heated argument with Alison Victor runs
to his old room which is now bends in
the new timeline on a stable there is a
drawing of a beautiful woman with the
name Jennifer scrawled on the bottom in
the comics the Jennifer incident is a
newspaper clipping posted in space boys
base on the moon the accompanying photo
is of Luther with his hand blocking the
camera lens there are various other
clippings visible including one with the
headline the horror dead in the comics
Ben is referred to as the horror and
with this scene from the series we can
assume that the Jennifer incident and
maybe even Jennifer herself caused Ben's
death in the original timeline
the opening scene from the season 1
finale revealed Abigail Hargreaves
Reginald's love from long ago it turns
out that Luther was guarding her
cryogenically frozen corpse on the moon
though he's unaware of that fact this
adds a much deeper purpose to Luther's
time on the moon while also exposing how
selfish Reginald is to sacrifice his
son's sanity and happiness revisiting
the flashback from season one there's
another detail far more significant
after the events of the new season the
glowing orange particles that Reginald
released into the air as the Rockets
were taking off are the source of power
for all the gifted children in the
series it's also fuel for the other
worldly machine that averted the
apocalypse for the third time could
Abigail be where the particles came from
there must be another way
Abigail is Reginald's singular purpose
for every merciless action he has taken
thus far this explains his triumphant
expression in the season 3 finale when
they're finally reunited
after the kugel Blitz annihilates
everything in sight the Umbrella Academy
makes a dramatic turn and instead of the
show's usual Fade to Black in the
credits it fades to a blinding white
this stylistic Choice emphasizes the
gravity of the situation the undeniable
power of the kugelblitz and the
Beautiful sacrifice Klaus makes so he
would still be around to help his
siblings the Fade to White could also
symbolize The White Buffalo that Klaus
killed himself on the White Buffalo has
a rich and deep Native American meaning
that represents hope and abundance this
is a surprisingly comforting note to end
on after the kugelblitz devours
everything but after the Umbrella
Academy saved the world twice it's not
wise to doubt them at this point Russo's
Angelic score pauses for a brief moment
before bursting into the rousing
Umbrella Academy theme this music change
reads as a fitting call to action for
Our Heroes to save the world yet again
if there is a fourth season of The
Umbrella Academy then we'll surely play
a big part in it the cryptic after
credits scene shows Ben sitting alone on
a subway train reading while you can't
exactly make out the book he's holding
you can overhear the conductor say where
Ben is arriving Ben is writing to the
yoido train station in South Korea but
what is he doing there could this be
related to the Jennifer incident one
thing is for sure saving the world
didn't bring Ben any closer to his
siblings if he's traveling all the way
to South Korea by himself his anger is
certainly justifiable but if he stays
alone and allows it to consume him he
could suffer a fate even worse than his
original Self it's also been speculated
that this bin is in fact the
doppelganger of the sparrow version of
the character if that's the case what
does it mean about potential doubles for
the other members of the family
the plaque that commemorates the
donation of obsidian Memorial Park feels
more like a slide against the saviors of
space and time rather than a
heartwarming tribute but knowing
Reginald and after seeing his egomania
run rampant and take over the city it
probably was meant to be a middle finger
to his kids the icing on the keg of
Reginald's less than sentimental
donation is that it was donated on their
birthday right down to the year Reginald
was willing to let all seven of his
gifted children die to be reunited with
Abigail it's easy to believe he's not
above a smug gracious donation such as
this
with their powers gone and the monocle's
true nature revealed what's next for
this dysfunctional bunch of former
superheroes hopefully a fourth season
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
the Umbrella Academy are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]